hey guys it's Peter Brown standing in
for freelancer Justin Clark playing
heavy rain reminds you that it's core
elements QuickTime events an interactive
drama we're ahead of their time in 2011
but in 2016 they ultimately feel dated
with a relatively new set of flaws to
boot the core plot is sound a serial
child murderer called the origami killer
is on the loose and the narrative
follows four perspectives during his
manhunt the game uses impossible camera
angles in QuickTime event prompts to add
weight to scenes where the threat of
consequences create a hectic atmosphere
that very few games match when he gets
down to business
creator David cages storytelling is
focused and engrossing but inconsistent
voice acting and the regular emphasis on
life's mundane moments proved to be
unfortunate distractions from the game's
larger or interesting themes and events
the ps4 version has some bugs that can
lead to jittery animations and clipping
issues that weren't present in the
original release re-releasing heavy
raining that's currently in scaped as
much too sharply contrasts everything
good and bad about it yet even as there
are game as I succeed where heavy rain
does not it can still be said that
there's almost nothing like it today
[Music]